your gloriana is a new mom what advice
do you have for riri i don't have any
advice i just have full-on
congratulations it's the best decision
that i was ever able to make and i know
she's just in pure bliss right now so
congrats girl i believe you both have
kids now y'all both are mamas life is
good life is great life is so good it
looks less that's what i am
are we going to promise i think we look
like we would be perfect for home days
um let's talk about this finale there
was a lot of tears tonight huh i'm tired
i need a nap i would take a margarita
instead of a nap but um i am really
tired yes because i have been through an
emotional rollercoaster
um and i'm just so grateful these kids
have grown so much and i just feel like
they're they're kind of like our our
children in some ways and they're just
it's just the growth is so beautiful i'm
so proud of this show
it really shows tonight really showed
like the power of american idol
you said it yourself it's changing lives
particularly with these kids i mean leah
she's saying firework as a kid and she
got to perform with you tonight
[Music]
how does it feel to be part of someone's
full circle moment like that it's wild
it's like she was nine years old and she
chose that then
maybe not ever thinking
something like this would happen and i
you know they asked if i wanted to sing
with a contestant and i had heard that
she had done that when she was younger
and i was like wow that would be so
powerful i don't think firework
everywhere just for presidents um liam
marlene tourism yes yes yes of course i
mean it was so special and it really i
you can tell how invested you guys are
in these kids and you mentioned it i
feel like it is like your kids like i
imagine parenthood has a huge influence
on that because it's almost as much
pride as you would have watching your
kid live out their dreams
i mean a hundred percent i mean the
humility and grace and character that
these contestants have i mean they're
all just great human beings which you
know you don't always get that in
artists coming up because they're you
know they're they're hustling and been
through a lot of life stuff but these
kids i mean whatever they've been
through they just use it
and do it gracefully and
yeah i mean it's amazing to see noah win
and see his family
you just won american idol
i was actually when they were all on
stage celebrating i was like holding his
child that's all that's all i wanted to
do all night was just hold this little
baby who was asleep i loved it i was
like the little
muffin ears asleep for his kid to watch
his dad on youtube in the future on
american idol
it's amazing a million dollar question
will you be back next season as a judge
i mean i hope they would have me this is
a really incredible job and i feel i
said it tonight i feel really uh
grateful and blessed to be in this
position to get to do this as a job to
be able to mentor and then also kind of
give like a life-changing lottery ticket
to kids this is this is living the dream
hashtag blessed hashtag
hashtag skinny margaritas hey you earned
it okay so cheers
who needs a sharp tequila when you have
nuggets i know she can't i've been away
for a whole week and i couldn't bring
her with me and so now i just saw her i
love her so reunited and it feels so
good
[Music]